こんにちははじめ戦争です非常に深刻な問題があります
ん
皆さん携帯ってシックなんすよねやギャラクシー室を使ってるんですけど
あのね動かなくなった
経済持っても川に落ちたりもしてないしそんな危ないってと言い方しないと思うんです
よねほんと壊れたんですよ
前に押す者
入らないし今3点入ってますよ漸減入って来
10年起訴しても
反動なんです
これは親弁なくも全然取れないぜ
ほんとやんなっちゃう twitter で情報を集めたら温めたら直るみたいな話を
聞いなんだよ今日スマホ電子レンジに入れて復活させようと思います
分かったお前ですねーかって言いたいことはわかる
ここが俺のいいじゃないホスト窓の家だかなぁ
天使レンズを壊すったら俺に責任があるかも分かっている
分かっているんだ
キズ折れ兄弟を治したいんだ
ごめんなさいよ僕ドドーンで買ったんですけどもどこのじゃないですどどうです
ブロック解除していじりせの追尾カードを使っているんで
これとサービスがないんですよ
携帯自体ちょっと理解してほしいのはもう完全にこの形態を完全にも
清浄機は僕にあるあるんで経済会社からサービスもないしもう前席には僕にあるんで
お前は見たような
契約してこうなんか全然放題とくださいんだぜ
そこら辺理解してくれ
じゃあいるからいい
データがも移すてねーな
俺が思いだ
お前にかかってるだけだったのーぞマジで爆発飛ばしたら本当にやめるぞ
部活とだけは本当になっ
はっはっは
ん
混ぜん
いきなりして指たーーー
よねー
かなぁ
ん
じゃーん
i am
なきゃいけ部で今日もい
おっ
tan
やよいえっ
じゃあもうつ入ってみようはいはダメだメディアが入れない方とエッ
ん
燃えてるよればこれはいい
これはやばい思えたらバレ
やばかっ思えたらやばい
どうぞそれでしょ
ではいっ
これぞれぞれだちょっと焦げたんですけど
まあまあ夫でしょいろんな口コミがあっても治るみたいなことって行ってこれ治ら
なかった俺ただのなんか
訪韓はみたいになっちゃいますよ頼みます本当願い
10ステージは本当にもちゃんとであります
cd ずだからな無理だろうな
恋
いっ
ん
dea